do we get to dance in this one just
start out dancing my cupcake is dead my
pizza is dead my heart is just like
leave it like blank for like you know
good 30 seconds then come back in no
good people would see you like this is
like 10 minutes or whatever so it's
ahead good quite cool the only way you
can form is if you really stop anyway
okay belly of the beast is this episode
this is where a giant monster swallows
up Finn and Jake and there's a bunch of
it's Care Bears I mean that's really
what they are they got the little Lobos
on their bellies is that I guess oh um I
don't know why they're Care Bears at the
same time I guess I never question why
there's like some Nintendo characters
running around or you know I don't think
it's not like an 8-bit nostalgic
qualities so no no that's going on and
they're just partying and they want to
stay in the monster's belly because they
think it's a lot of fun and they love to
answer partying but Finn and Jake won't
get them out cuz I got turned into the
stuff I love that's what they call it oh
and and it gets even worse because the
monster wants to get rid of him so he
tries eating or drinking lava and so
they had to go out through the butt
intestine yeah but intestine yes thank
you
and at the very end they're just like oh
well that didn't work for anybody we
really won't be back in the belly so
instead using fireworks which I guess
they were using though you never see him
set him off you seem open his mouth in
the fire yeah but you never see Matt you
said it off buddy so it's like we're who
is lighting those who was it doesn't
matter so I decide to use lasers and the
Monster eats them up and everybody's
happy I guess somebody make a gif of
that um they're ready one two one of me
going like that oh yeah
but yeah so it's it's better than okay
but um I I didn't know where was going
at means that like Mystery Train you
know it's just like okay well what are
you gonna do next year um and I do sort
of like that what the hell is a guy
party pet party pad yeah I like you I
like his whole just a sort of mellow way
just giving into the party and I really
like that Joe gray say like you didn't
party you move your legs but you did not
dance you have to use your mind's eye
and you just die just game it's just a
sticker it's like again I like it way to
really fool me because you really think
that's like the angle they got to yeah
no no so so that was funny and hey it's
cute I guess I sort of got sick of being
in that belly obvious ever had a party
too long it's just like yeah I really
want to go but whatever like my friend
is like he's my ride and he's an athlete
he's drunk or I don't know but like a
lot of your parties but yeah it was like
it's not like that you're just are stuck
in this place with these lights
I find that was a lot of clubs actually
like you know a club it's like fun for
like a little band that's like yeah okay
time to go and everyone wants to stay
like ten times longer than they need to
never liked clubs
I don't like yelling at my friends just
to talk I I do when I was younger and
now it's like now they're just like
maybe that's it man just like I have
like that just looks terrible like this
used to be really fun now it's just like
yeah we had to yell and you can't hear
anybody and you're going deaf and the
main guy sleeps on a waterbed that's a
heart I do love that that's something I
wanted there's a give up just him on the
heart is good I don't know why that just
tears do you think he got into that bed
I don't know I go you tell which ones
were female but yeah I mean it was just
strange enough for me to like it and be
like okay like I'm glad I saw that
everything but like not
not quite as crazy as I was hoping it to
be for such a funny idea I like the idea
that there's a party going on the Billy
and the why are you just still stuck on
the whole Marceline Finn thing oh yeah
but I was gonna keep it focused but if
you want to go that route yeah uh here's
another fanfiction I came up with I
think that they should go into the land
of the dead you know see the father
again I think Finn should be helping
them out through some sort of like
Dennis nightly where they're from the
nightosphere lambda the Dead is
completely different okay so in my
fanfiction they're exactly the same and
that's the big twist is that the father
actually always put the line of the Dead
and the nightosphere he does that too so
uh and but and finn helps them get along
so well that the father decides you know
what i'm gonna give you the land of the
dead while I rule the nightosphere and
they live so happily and then they you
know decide hey we should be a couple
but we're not gonna get married because
that's you know we're like still kids
and stuff even we get older it's just a
marriage isn't really our thing we're
just gonna you know live free party hard
all that stuff and if it's gonna be like
yeah and then eventually he's gonna grow
old and value Marceline is gonna be
really sad but that you realize that's
the great tragic love and then the
credits are gonna roll and all the women
are gonna cry and the guys are gonna be
like dude she was hot and everything's
gonna be good so shouldn't Marceline
like commit suicide when Finn dies uh no
it's too much of a downer
just like Finn died it's fine it's like
that Lord the Rings thing we live Tyler
and you know arrow there we go around Z
you know he's like the statue he got
turned into a statu no that's not it but
it's like that finish return to a statue
somebody write this weird ass fanfiction
okay just make it happen with everything
I just said and get a pickle in there
too somehow and send it to me do not
send it to me as soon as I said that
like I'm like shit now everyone's gonna
like write this up if you like read it
you're the only one who are the exact
same fantasies be pickle at all so yeah
I think you were just too preoccupied
with the last episode that like you you
couldn't really get into this one I was
doing five you know I was okay wait we
get the episode it was
I knew it's okay no I think you're too
preoccupied with the last ones are just
not see the genius of it no if you would
let me go on no talk about the geniuses
well I was going out about the episode
then you're like oh you're still
thinking about the Marceline episode and
stuff and monotone this time around
you're just like well it's not as good
as that episode Danny you just foiled me
no I mean it was an okay episode it
definitely wasn't up there with some of
the better ones and it is kind of hard
to come off of such a good episode to
this one where it's like gay could be
better if I saw it in a different order
you know it is sort of like the Mystery
Train one because then that come right
after the Susan strong episode yeah so
say that is kind of interesting actually
to be fair they probably do that purpose
to you they probably uh for the balance
yeah so it's not like you know a long
you know a string of like really really
good ones in that just a string of like
nothing but crap like what Walking Dead
did and then they have like a season
finale where it's like holy crap and you
just had to wait there like nine
episodes of nothing happening to getting
you do enough on other things I am I
just want to get that out there that
that wasn't cool because you know like I
missed the episode I came home and my
wife's like you you all know what happen
like yeah tell me what happened okay
it's like everything happened there's a
frickin tank in it it's like thanks
walking dead it's like the one episode I
said just tell me what happens I don't
care in like friggin arm again happens
too it's like if there's an arm akin to
that would be it so it's like a Michael
Bay movie Michael baby I walking good
okay imagine arm again but with zombies
and a tank in space no but they'll
probably be after the mid-season finale
I I think we can get the walkers in this
space that's what they call them the
water I'm like I'm very so I liked the
Bears and how they were like you have
the one that has like the set of
dentures on their stomach yeah I was
like what the one with the bomb was
about it's like really add up they have
all the strange things I was waiting to
do a Care Bear stare yeah it's like I'm
waiting for some sort of Care Bears joke
and maybe that
is the joke just that they never ever do
anything with it that's possible but
because the first time we see them
they're partying with the Ice King and
everything so I'm assuming they're
partying again but I'll did I is there
an episode a party with the ice cream
I'll remember oh my god you were going
on this huge thing about the mole to
skull and crossbones I like that's death
bear I want to know his story I totally
don't remember that so anyone out there
that thinks that I give away spoilers I
also get him right away he doesn't I
don't even remember skull bear or
whatever it was do you remember the Lich
no Lynch yeah no see exactly my points
this guy doesn't know this is why I need
this cuz I'll forget all these things so
don't yell at me about giving away
spoilers cuz he won't remember anyways
what yeah pisode was it what the one
where the Bears were with the Ice King
no bummer he's gonna get married oh
that's right there were bears in there I
really don't remember okay hi what don't
leave me please don't put your coat on
it's really doing it's putting his coat
up don't do that I quit no I'm Mouse
without you okay bring it to me let's go
let's go
okay okay let's go it on so i'm debbie
to your dump on the roll
14 14 year old Oh
Becky's it's okay this is the most
disturbing ending we've had yet
five